[Music]
october is breast cancer awareness month
and this morning we're taking a look
into a very concerning trend involving
the number of young women being
diagnosed with stage 4 breast cancer
women under the age of 40 account for
six percent of total stage four cases
one study shows more than four percent
increase per year in stage four breast
cancer cases and women in their 20s and
their 30s from 2016 to
this is concerning the researchers don't
really know why this is happening cbs
news senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula spoke with 30-year-old paige
stables she was diagnosed with stage
four breast cancer back in april now
stables is a beauty editor for allure
magazine and she wrote about living with
the diagnosis in this month's issue
[Music]
the thought of stage 4 breast cancer in
your 20s or 30s seems unimaginable
until it happens
truly in a moment my worst nightmare
became my reality
i was 26 years old i was doing a
self-exam
and i found a lump in my right breast
and
within a month i underwent a bilateral
mastectomy
this past march i celebrated being three
years cancer-free and
then
around that same time i started to feel
a pain in my hip when they told you it
had metastasized to your hip what became
your concerns at that point for the
future your whole world just stops and
it's a completely
different conversation when
you find out you have breast cancer and
that that alone is life-changing and
challenging but when you find out that
it's stage four it just it is so
different i would be lying if i said
it's easy i've always said that
positivity is my shield
in the article that you wrote you used
the word thrivers
why thrivers we are thrivers because we
are going to be living with this the
rest of our life and
oncologists told me that it's almost
like a chapter book
and
hopefully these are going to be really
really long chapters in terms of
right now i'm doing a certain treatment
and hopefully that chapter will continue
for a really long time and if we need to
turn the page
and do another treatment then we can do
that but
i
am not
looking ahead to that ending anytime
soon
tell me a little bit about the advice
that your doctor gave you she said two
simple words celebrate life
and
since that moment that's what i've done
it's
big celebrations and small celebrations
and just really living my life to the
fullest
[Music]
paige's cancer is stage four she is
currently undergoing hormonal therapies
to manage the cancer a monthly injection
and a daily pill she's required to get a
pet scan every three months to make sure
the cancer isn't spreading looking
forward paige is planning her with her
wedding in italy for next fall boy does
she have the right attitude i love what
she said tara that positivity is her
shield yes i think that's something we
can all learn something from listening
to her words but we were saying in the
lead doctors aren't really quite sure
why this is happening 20s 30s is so
young to get this diagnosis right the
experts don't know why well there's no
clear understanding at this point but it
is a trend both here and abroad and
there are theories about why we might be
seeing this for example exposures in
your lifestyle so inflammation stress
your diet toxins
also we know that there's not great
screening for women under 40. so we
definitely need more research into what
we could do to capture these smaller you
know less often cases of women who are
young uh because there's less screening
we tend to find these cancers at later
stages also the cancers that are
occurring in these younger women tend to
be more aggressive and so it speaks to
the fact that the biology of this type
of cancer may be different but the
bottom line is it's so tricky and
challenging this is a population of
women who are dealing with fertility
issues if they're having treatment in
the beginnings of their you know career
they have families so there's a unique
set of challenges around this population
she made a point of talking about the
importance of she caught it during a
self-breast exam which illustrates again
how important it is for us to do that
are we supposed to start at a certain
age so interestingly self-breast exams
and clinical breast exams are actually
not officially recommended because the
research has not backed those up as
being beneficial that being said most
experts say it's still a good idea to
know how your breasts normally look and
feel and in fact paige caught her own
cancer a week after she had seen her
doctor who had done an exam so you do
need to be your own health advocate and
if you feel something or see something
speak up to your doctor about it wow now
when it comes to treatment chemotherapy
used to be the standard but people are
moving away from that what are the
alternatives isn't that great so
chemotherapy was really kind of the only
go-to for so many years and about 10 to
15 years ago we started to shift towards
these more targeted therapies like
hormonal therapies biologics
immunologics and that's based on
actually genetically looking at the
tumor itself and figuring out what the
tumor will best be responsive to the
value in that is that you're sparing
women those side effects of the chemo
the hair loss
the nausea the fatigue and also nerve
damage and in my world cardio toxicity
we talked about this last year but a lot
of women survive their breast cancer and
go on to die from cardiovascular disease
because of the chemo that they might
have received now what increases the
risk of breast cancer so there are a lot
of potential factors so we talk a lot
about genetics so bracha 1 and bracket 2
mutations family history if you yourself
have a personal history previously of
breast cancer also some benign breast
conditions and then other things like if
you had early onset of your periods late
menopause if you never had children if
you never breastfed some exposures like
alcohol and tobacco so a lot of
different factors good to talk to your
doctor about whether you might be at
increased risk what about signs and
symptoms because i noticed she said she
felt something and then she talked about
a pain in her hip right so the most
common sign and symptom is going to be a
new lump or mass but certainly if you
notice a change in the shape of your
breast swelling of the breast also any
change in the texture of the skin so
redness or dimpling
or any dry flaky skin that's kind of
continuing on nipple inversion or
discharge that's not breast milk and
then if you notice a swollen node under
your arm or around your collarbone those
are things you should be pointing out to
your doctor all right valuable
information yeah yeah i mean she's an
amazing woman and she hopes that really
her story and those stories of the women
she profiled will be inspirational to
others because of their strength to show
that there's hope even though they don't
have the cure
well i like her philosophy celebrate
life that's right continue living i love
that she's making sure with her wedding
plans i also like her philosophy of
getting married in italy yeah but it's
nice to do it i think i hear that i like
that too
she's made a point of saying breast
cancer does not define me yes cheering
you on fade staples cheering you on